oui j'aime bien qu'on baise moi on en
fait on a vu à palau gens en tant
qu'invité je l'appelle tout il n'ya pas
longtemps tant qu'invité et généralement
on dit qu'on rêve des personnes qu'on
avait juste avant et il est passé par la
fenêtre comme des vers et des quoi j'ai
rêvé que mais c'était cool quoi
et vous qu'est né voilà la belle julia
kobe tu sais c'est exceptionnel c'est
réel aux personnes me kane caire avant
d'en arriver là lâche julien bon jus de
la joya julien courbet mon chéri c'est
cyril hanouna on est en direct mon chéri
monsieur non mais je t'explique g que
des bonnes nouvelles pour toit sur la
tête de ma mère ton émission sur europe
1 elle s'appelle ça peut vous arriver
non parce que je chante ici pour l'année
prochaine
j'ai besoin de toi sur europe 1 ça
s'appelle ça peut vous arriver sur intel
bat frérot toi ça peut t'arriver frère
tu veux que je lisais ya une main il ya
une meuf dans tpm paix qui a rêvé de toi
et frérot
je sais pas si vous parlez comme ça sur
rtl mais tu la connais pas beaucoup
non tu l'as fait indiquée sur frère tu
vas pas me croire une nouvelle intrigue
à litière frère a tout autant alors je
te raconte le rêve à l'arrivée bon bien
sûr que tu passais pas par la porte eut
passé par la fenêtre
bien sûr frérot la saris dans la chambre
elle te dis est ce que tu peux te mettre
tout nu là tu lui réponds sans aucun
doute
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
adam gadahn est finie la tuer dit tu
veux sortir marc merguez chez le roi des
barbecues ou encore julia cela et tu la
pêche en france et qui sait pas ce que
tu veux toi dans ta tête tu dis c'est
isabelle non sécurisés haussier du
tennis et de bélie babel à quoi
répondait tout le monde pas la priorité
[Applaudissements]
je suis appelé je suis donc là de te
dire je suis emballé de dire que je fais
la plus grosse connerie le ta job à
temps sur m6 non d'accord mais bien sûr
l arrivée 2 ou 3 frères el harti lui
c'est parce que oui elle a rêvé de toi
quand tu es venu elle s'est endormie
avec la danse dans la tête et je peux
vous dire qu'elle devait verser un don
kelly a rêvé de toi et frérot
apparemment franchement faire c'est bien
ça va ce n'est pas le plombier pour
savoir si les tuyaux il était bien la
mission
qu'est ce qu'il ya il la rappelle juste
après le décompte est venu chez elle à
la pâte à icloud du renard sauver
d'autres
je viens en tout cas voilà qu'elle y
arrive et toi donc 0 et sur l'autoroute
je sais pas autant d sentimentalement
mais règlent tous a dit est bien noir
auquel 0
[Rires]
et junas je n'ai insulté un art show si
tu pouvais vraiment pécho kelly se
serait capital pour elle et pour nous
merci
[Applaudissements]
oh